here's a story from the Daily Mail
sickening footage released by Hamas
shows terrorists holding Israeli
Toddlers and children during Saturday's
Massacre which shocked the world
sickening footage released by Hamas
today allegedly shows a terrorist
holding Israeli toddlers the video shows
Hamas members holding the youngsters
that say sit around a table one is
seeing rocking a prom as an infant cries
others are carrying the distressed
children rocking them and patting their
backs the footage was recorded during uh
during as Hamas gunmen carried out their
Mass infiltration of Israel last
Saturday according to Israeli newspaper
the Jerusalem Post the attack saw Hamas
prescribed as a terrorist organization
by the EU and the US burst through the
heavily militarized border around the
Gaza Strip This we all know took an
estimated 150 Israeli foreign and dual
Nationals uh National hostages back to
Gaza during its initial attack Hamas
said on Friday that 13 of them had been
killed in Israeli air strikes it has
previously said four hostages died in
the bombardments so you can see here
they have images of them taking the
children now I suppose the the claim
they're trying to make is that they
didn't kill the kids there's also videos
where Hamas Fighters are
indiscriminately firing into
porta-potties so this is all propaganda
from a group that is out of
control sadistic targeting civilians if
if one if one Hamas guy or palestin
naturist comes out and says that they
believe in peace it doesn't matter
because clearly there is no unified
message as to what they're doing they're
going and indiscriminately just killing
and capturing civilians and we know they
use them as bargaining chips so here we
are again in this uh in the circumstance
and and the craziest thing is right now
on the left the only thing they're
saying is Israel's killing babies this
is it is this is the nightmare scenario
of War but I got to be completely honest
they will make that the left makes the
argument that Israel started it when
quite literally Hamas broke the barriers
down and went and started targeting
civilians so you know you want to take
this back thousands of years fine so be
it but Hamas is targeting civilians and
children Israel targeting militarized
sites or whatever is not the same thing
though we are all distressed when
civilians die that's that's a no-brainer
I mean what the Defenders of Hamas in
this country and the West are doing is
they're trying to dispute a wholesale
Truth by making sort of retail
objections and what I mean by that is
they'll say this particular image is
distorted or this is not a valid video
as if to say that and and maybe they're
right because we're in an age where
there's so much fog of War there's so
much confusion about whether this video
was digitally altered sometimes
difficult for you or I to know but the
implication is that if the video is
invalid kids are not being threatened by
Hamas and and I think we shouldn't lose
sight of that bigger truth sort of that
that V that picture of the burned baby
that uh Ben Shapiro posted yesterday and
then the AI machine said hey it's
actually fake and it's like yo maybe
it's real maybe it's fake matter it is
real apparently now but who knows if
that's even true but It ultimately
doesn't matter because they did kill
babies and very likely burned them alive
I don't know it doesn't matter if that
picture is real or fake the these these
videos of Hamas storming these houses
and then you can see one guy lighting a
house on fire yo they're not checking
the bedrooms to make sure innocent
people aren't dying they're opening fire
on closed porta-potties with people in
them they don't care and I should say
it's very very self-righteous me to say
that they are I it seems as if they are
from reports that I've read that they
were indiscriminately murdering old
women people bro there's there's videos
like look I just watched a video where
they're walking through the music
festival and there's a row of portal
potties and just go pop pop pop like
come on man there could be kids in there
there could be women when we see them in
one video waiting at the Gate of a kabut
and then a car pulls up they wait for
the gate to open run up and execute the
people inside the car they're not
checking to see if that's an elderly
women or not they're just opening fire
on the car and then running in they're
not checking to see if there's people in
the room they walk into the house and
then start setting things on fire
there's a so when we see photos that are
being published that don't show the
bodies they show blood and they show you
know Gore and stuff like that I really
don't think that the Israel government
is manufacturing scenes when we can see
the videos and we know that even
journalists of a more pro pro Palestine
bent are saying yeah they target
civilians it's one of their tactics I
there's videos of them holding children
my guess is that civilians are making
fake content governments are making fake
content on all Ides but that also
there's lots of real content as well and
it's terrifying me cuz like I was saying
earlier I tweet I want to go look at the
most gruesome stuff where is that I want
to see it and then as I was thinking
about I was like I don't I don't want to
get tricked into seeing gruesome stuff
from two years ago or things that like
fake Gru gruesome stuff that makes me
crazy so I don't even know if I want to
look at any of it now but I don't want
to not know what's going on so the the
big controversy the other day which
everybody get mads about gets mad about
you've got the the the you know very
pro-israeli side and Ang that anyone
would dare question the authenticity of
this photo posted by Israel you've got
people on the left arguing that it's not
real and if you're saying it is oh no
you're posting fake nonsense I don't
care about that I care about actually
investigating the story and figure out
who's lying now what had happened was we
I did an AI or not analysis on the photo
that was posted by the Israeli Prime
Minister and Ben Shapiro had posted the
same image and it said it was AI I then
put an AI generated image in it said it
was AI I then put in a graphic designed
by humans it said it was made by humans
we I then put in a photograph of John
fedman that we got from a news story we
used for a thumbnail and it said it was
a real it was a human generated photo so
it was accurate I don't know if the the
photo of the baby in this regard was uh
or I should say definitively right now
it was inaccurate as it pertained to
that the charred remains of that of that
baby uh there has been a much deeper
analysis where they actually posted the
forensic analysis of the image and the
manip other manipulations that were made
to it it appears to be Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt the photo is real it is
a is a real photo of a real doctor
showing the remains and uh it's it's
kind of horrifying that this this is
what happens first it's horrifying that
people are like I demand to see the
photo to prove it and that's that's sad
and that's horrifying at first they're
like look for privacy reasons we we
don't want to show these things but
people demand the proof so it gets
posted and then what happens is
propagandists and people trying to
to I guess win a win win an information
War then claim it's all fake and then
finally we get a bunch of different AI
forensic analysis one of the things they
did was there's some tools where it
shows you uh uh like pixel patterns and
like things like that that you can't see
with your own eyes right but when you
run it through some several filters you
can clearly see lines where AI is
generated the original image doesn't
appear to be fake and then there are
faked versions of it that are clearly
fake so I I would just say at this point
who knows I believe to the best of our
abilities it's it's a legit photo and
this is stuff's horrifying but again I
don't I don't think we need at this
point when there's videos of Hamas
laughing holding the kids they're
clearly the terrorist Mo has not changed
if you go back to the um ' 70s when you
had the IRA and you had the you know the
um incident at anbi and so on the the
idea of taking hostages the idea of
exploiting the other side's reverence
for human life I mean think about it
they know that the Israelis care about
human life if the Israelis really didn't
care the hostages would be meaningless
the reason that they grab your kid as a
hostage is they know that you're going
to go okay you know I'm going to so so
it reminds me a little bit how in this
country you know they use the accusation
of racism I'm not think of this just by
by way of analogy when somebody comes to
you and says you're a
racist their hidden assumption is that
you're not a racist because if you were
really a racist you'd be like thank you
very much this is awesome you know what
it's like someone coming to me goes
you're Indian I'd be like yeah sure but
they want you to go no I'm not so the
fact that you go no I'm not is you don't
believe you are and you don't want to
think of yourself as a racist so the
charge of racism only works on
anti-racists not anti-racist though they
they they' CED that phrase anti-racist
to them it works on people who are not
racist exactly yeah because it because
it hits them where it hurts if if
someone who's genuinely racist and proud
of it it would not hurt at all they
would take it as a compliment this is
this this is a very clever game they
play they've TR they they took the
phrase anti-racist because people assume
it means you oppose racism it doesn't
anti-racist means you're quite literally
racist but in a different
way that's a good point they've that's
right this this appropriation of
vocabulary and the left is really good
at this I mean the resistance you know
the uh even the language of
decolonization I mean decolonization is
a good idea right I mean I'm from India
India was a colony of the British if you
say
decolonization but over the years the
Indians have sort of reassessed because
they've now realized yeah there were
some bad things from the British but
guess what you know we still wear suits
we still have British laws we still have
parliamentary systems of government we
got a lot of things from the British so
uh but but nevertheless this this strope
of anti-colonialism is driving this
whole narrative that's what makes the
Palestinians into Heroes and the
Israelis into villains how Bloody was
the uh Indian Revolution if it was even
considered a revolution against the
British When They seized control it was
one of the UN bloodiest Revolutions of
all because Gandhi recognized that the
Indians were they outnumbered the
British were ruling India with a very
small contingent of people and so Gandhi
realized listen all we need to do is
sort of paralyze the country with
nonviolent demonstrations and it'll be
too difficult for the British to kind of
manage this Indian elephant and so the
British sort of essentially Let It Go
and but again the the only reason the
Indians could pull that off is because
the British were not Hitler I mean if
the British were Hitler Gandhi would be
you know
lampshade God
literally but the Indians could count on
the fact that they could go light on the
tracks the railway tracks and all the
British trains would go they grind to a
halt because again the British are not
willing to run over Indian kids yeah uh
and so that ultimate the British their
own morality was the undoing of the
Empire wow and I think we're
seeing very in the United States
elements of the the Liberals and the
left that are anti-america and hate this
country country there's a video right
now going around of someone on I think
it's on Fox I'm not sure where they're
asking a person at this one of these
protests in New York supporting Hamas
saying you know do you believe America
should take care of itself first like
absolutely not and it's like okay well
when you have a large faction of
Americans maybe half the country who are
like America last okay well you've got
problems with pipes and Flint or Newark
or whatever insert country but you want
to send our money overseas first this
country will not survive that it's like
you're you're it's you're you're giving
away your money to your neighbor before
paying your rent eventually you get
evicted yeah sooner or later I mean one
of the things I found then going back to
my just experience growing up was that
India had these wars with Pakistan and I
noticed that while those wars were going
on every Indian was on the Indian side
for the exact same reason that every
Indian backs the Indian side in the
cricket match you know nationalism India
first is taken for granted nobody even
debates it it's not like you have to
discuss is it a good idea to be India
first I mean no Indian would even know
what that means yeah and And yet when I
came to the United States suddenly I
realized and this is in some way a
legacy of the Vietnam War suddenly I
realized a lot of Americans actually are
not on the American side they actually
want the Vietnamese to win they are
America last and they see America as a
villainous force in the world even
though America's been a very benign
force in the world any other country
that had this kind of power that the US
has had since World War II would have
used it far more tyrannically oh yeah
definely it's almost like a tell when
you when someone says that the US is
like the most racist country in the
world hear all time like you have not
traveled anywhere quite literally like
the least racist country like even I
bring this up when I went to Sweden they
try to claim they're very Progressive
but they're super racist they're like we
we we we Scuttle all the poor people
into these ghettos and then tell
everyone how how awesome we are but then
we only hire white Natives and in the
United States you've got white liberals
without group preference and there was a
story that came out that found I think
over the past several years something
like 90 plus% of mid to high level jobs
were all given to non-white individuals
because of the Dei push so it's like
that's clearly racist and in violation
of the 1964 Civil Rights Act but here we
are thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net next
time